[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRITTANY WILBERT: Rosie is based
on Rosie the Riveter, the very
famous icon during
World War II era
to get women involved in a
lot of the mechanical work.
We used foam for the head as
well as some of the parts.
So even though it was
relatively basic, it was still,
you know, an achievement
because we worked overnight.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPRIHA BARUAH: We started off
with a remote control car,
and then we used the
chassis of the car
to experiment with the
robot on top of that.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
They split Rosie
into two electrical circuits.
The bottom portion was meant
for the movement of the robot
controlled by a mobile app.
And the top portion
was meant to capture
their facial expressions
and, as her response,
offer to shake their hand.
SPRIHA BARUAH: The
app that was meant
to control the car base
wasn't actually working.
And we spent a lot
of time on the app,
like looking at
all the settings.
But it turns out
that we just hadn't
connected the Wi-Fi
antenna to the hardware.
BRITTANY WILBERT: It
was just, you know,
really cool to not have to
worry so much about having
to create a whole new library
and whole new set of tools,
and instead use what was
already available to get started
a lot quicker.
When I heard that
they were going
to have a third party developer
finish sort of the design work
that I was working on, and
then to see it in person
and see that it was literally
the same height as me,
maybe a little bit
taller with the wheels,
I was beyond ecstatic about it.
It was really cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHEN HAWES: When we first
got the project for Rosie,
there was a prototype.
And our job was
to make it bigger,
make it so she could
take pictures with you,
drive around an event, and
make her have a large presence
in a conference setting.
There are some really big
motors down in that base.
They're actually from
an electric wheelchair.
We have two car batteries
wired together in series
to make sure she has enough
voltage and enough amperage
to be able to get around.
The board inside Rosie
is capable of all kinds
of different ML functions.
It's connecting with
Google API, so by adding
some external sensors
to her, we were
able to increase her
functionality and interact
with people at a
much higher level.
MELISSA DANIELS:
You can actually
do on-device processing and use
all the Google services that
are actually available, and
pick and choose the APIs
that you really wanted to use.
DENIA DEL CID: The biggest
thing that I learned
was to use the platform itself.
Now it has inspired me
to start new projects,
and it's become so
easy to work on them.
BRITTANY WILBERT:
With Android Things,
it's really cool because
it allows you to, you know,
just jump in.
The Android Things team has a
lot of support on their website
and has a lot of tooling
that's readily available
so you don't have to
just start from scratch.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: Try
out a few code labs.
Once you try a code lab or two,
you will get the hang of it.
And then you can build
your dream project.
SPRIHA BARUAH: Give it a try.
Go download Android Studio.
Get a Raspberry Pi.
Get one of our development kits.
And just get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]